هذا بيتي الثاني
يعني لو قالوا لي اطلع من الشغل بدها كل
يوم اجي استمر اجي لو بطلع عليها وبقعد
ربي فنجان قهوه فيها
يعني الناس المحتاجين
ارامل عندي ناس يعني فعلا محتاجين يعني
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي سمير امين جابر صباح خاص سلطان
اللي ما يعادل
27 سنه في الاوقات العامه
اشتغلت عده شغلات في الاوقاف الا انه
تقريبا 22 سنه
يعني
في بيتي
بقدم للناس يعني الناس المحتاجين
ارامل ناس يعني فعلا محتاجين يعني
انا بعتبرها بيتي الثانيه ومن شان هيك
يعني
بكون يعني
يوم ما باجي وبدخل باب بوابه هذه
بشعر يعني بحنين لها يعني
بلش البئس
شايف كيف بدي اقوم
يعني الطاقه اللي بدي اطبخ فيها بصير اعبر
فيها مثلا زي اللحمه بحطه هذا
البرازيل وبعدين
انا يوماتي
[موسيقى]
بطلع من بيتي تقريبا الفجر الساعه خمسه
بوصل
تقريبا خمسه ونصف الا ربع باجي بغير يعني
ببلش
اغسل لحمه تقريبا
اذا في عندي اخواني اصير افتح مثلا بكجات
اذا عندي قصيده خضراء او بازيلا جزر او
بندقيه او يعني عده اشياء في عندي او
باميه يعني ببلش اطبخ على الطناجر الثانيه
تاكيد
ببلش اطبق فيه
[موسيقى]
انا مخصص يوم الاحد بالذات نخصص طناجر
بنسوي شوربه الكريشه اللي بسموها شوربه
تركيه يعني عنا اهل القدس بيسموها شوربه
التيه لكن هي عباره عن جريشه قمح بنطبخها
هون والحمد لله يعني
خاصه داخل الكيمياء لو اعطيتها لمين مكان
يطبخها في بيته يختلف الطعم اختلاف
[موسيقى]